[Musik]
hallo meins ach nee Köln sorry die
Narren Kappen sehen überall gleich aus
ich weiß ihr wollt einfach mal ein Abend
Spaß und gute Laune aber das könnt ihr
vergessen gibt nichtich zu lachen das
wird ein
scheißjahr Humor war gestern es ist
Februar 2024 hat gerade erst angefangen
und wenn ich mir die Weltlage so angucke
wird das ja genauso unlustig wie eure
Verkleidungen also nee bitte ernsthaft
die Frau da in der zweiten Reihe was
soll denn das sein sexy Krankenschwester
oder
Zombie schwer zu sagen also seid ihr
besoffen genug für schlechte
Nachrichten dachte ich mir die
Wirtschaft schrumpft die Preise steigen
weiter das Bildungssystem ist kaputt die
Bahn ist noch kaputter die Energiewende
geht nicht voran die Digitalisierung
stockt soll ich
weitermachen mein Ziel dieses Jahr so
unbeliebt zu werden wie der
Bundeskanzler ja alle hassen Olaf im
Beliebtheitsranking liegt Scholz aktuell
auf Platz
F Plätze hinter friedrichz das musst du
auch erstmal hinkriegen also ich muss ja
reinen Moment
kretze Herpes ein Stück Holz alles
beliebter als der Scholz selbst die
Nervensäge merärz das ist doch wohl ein
schlechter Scherz derart schlechtes
Personal gibt sonst nur im
[Musik]
Karneval stimmt doch wir sind los Nation
nicht mal mehr die letzte Generation
will noch arbeiten die haben offiziell
angekündigt sich nicht mehr auf der
Straße festzukleben und wollen jetzt
umsteigen auf
spachsschrauben das findet ihr lustig
war ja klar dabei sind die paar
klimakleber gar nicht das Problem wir
haben im September drei Landtagswahlen
Sachsen ur und Thüringen überall ist die
AFD ganz vorne mit dabei als neue
völkische Volkspartei schön dass gerade
alle gegen Rechts auf die Straße gehen
aber machen wir uns doch nichts vor nach
diesen Wahlen will man über Thüringen
nicht mal mehr drüber fliegen schade ich
meine Thüringen ist eigentlich ein
schönes Land leckere
wurstgötee viel Wald dasau
us Wurst Wald ja sowas wirft man nicht
der AFD zum frasvor Liebe Thüringer
innen wollt ihr das Grundgesetz
entkernen wollt ihr alle Russisch lernen
ich weiß nicht wann ihr das mal lernt
man wählt nicht den
Faschisten
Bernt Vorschlag machen wir ein
Naturschutzgebiet draus und ziehenen
Zaun drum fertig dann können die da ihre
ethnisch homogenen Klöse fressen mir
rückgol was ist noch kaputt ach ja die
Bundeswehr unsere Truppe ist nach wie
vor nicht mal in der Lage eine
Schneeballschlacht zu gewinnen wenn
Trump wieder Präsident wird und aus der
NATO rausgeht dann stehen wir aber
richtig blöd da wenn Putin sich die DDR
zurückholen will vielleicht müssen wir
im Verteidigungsfall mal out of the box
denken und da kommt ihr ins Spiel unsere
schöne Bundeswehr verteidigt überhaupt
nichts mehr ich sag wenn der Russe kommt
rote Funken an die
Front wo bleibt der Tusch verdammt noch
mal warum denn nicht Uniformen habt ihr
doch schon und eure Karnevalswagen fah
zumindest ich habe es euch gesagt das
wird kein schönes Jahr und wenn ihr
meint die fußballem im Sommer sorgt für
gute
Laune die findet zwar in Deutschland
statt aber nach der Vorrunde ohne
Deutschland da üben wir schon mal den
dexit den deutschen Ausstieg aus Europa
den die AFD so gerne will so alles
schlecht gelernt super
wenigstens eine Sache kriegen wir hin ab
April kommt wahrscheinlich die Cannabis
Legalisierung aber ich sehe schon in den
rosigen Gesichtern hier das ist nicht
die klassische karnevalsdroge
nee Deutschland ist links grrün versifft
drum wird hier bald legal gekifft doch
die doofen Jecken hier trinken lieber
Kölner Bier
kösch dass ich so gerne disse denn es
schmeckt wie
Katzen kommt einer geht noch klickt auf
die Links um mehr zu sehen denn
Hassknecht will nach Hause gehen ihr
könnt auch gern aufs Abo drücken vom
blöd hier rumstehen krieg ich
[Musik]
Rücken